so picking up with the books of doom
part 4 if I'm going to be honest with
you guys
this I think is the best issue of the
whole series and the reason why is
because there's no great big huge you
know doom trying to hide himself in the
world there's none of that stuff this
focuses almost exclusively on Victor Von
Doom and how he views himself now will
show him getting to the temple and we'll
learn that kind of stuff before the
first half of this it's strictly doom
and how he views himself and this is why
I love this so much because Ed grew
Baker does an amazing job of looking
beyond the character of the doom that we
know and looking at him beyond the mask
and who he is on a fundamental level
what he tells us is that climbing the
mountain was treacherous in the extreme
to say nothing of the fact that Otto did
not give doom a map he didn't give him
an exact location doom had to basically
wonder around Tibet and find this place
on his own he had to wonder around and
ask different people if they knew
anything about it the problem with this
is that this temple of monks was so
secretive that even those individuals
who did have some inkling of information
about them we're not really willing to
come forward and give them that info now
something that I do want to point out
here for those of you guys who are
Doctor Strange fans or who know a little
bit about Doctor Strange this is not the
same temple as the ancient one this is a
totally separate location the ancient
ones temple is around the same region
but this is a different set in and of
itself now there are a lot of
similarities between doom and Doctor
Strange and there is actually a team up
that deals with Mephisto with Doctor
Doom and Doctor Strange and of course
I'll cover that once we get closer to
the release of the Doctor Strange movie
but the fact remains that for Victor Von
Doom he always sort of saw himself as
above normal humans he always saw
himself as above everybody virtually
everybody that he met but the issue with
this experience is that it's so humbling
because he's had to behest of everybody
else
if he truly wants to find this temple if
he truly wants to find this location
he's going to have to rely on the help
of strangers in order to access it to
say nothing of his own individual wits
and his own intelligence now the other
half of this is doom still struggles
with the dreams and the nightmares that
he experiences at the manipulations of
Mephisto now during his time with
valaria she was sort of a sedative and
and doom even addresses this he says the
Valyria was a sedative for these
nightmares when he was with her he
wasn't experiencing these dreams now
this tells us a couple things that
as first that mephisto power over doom
is limited strictly to how much doom
allows Mephisto to influence him and is
also due to the fact that doom end of
himself in terms of how he is right now
is still relatively weak minded he's
strong and intelligent in terms of his
capabilities but when it comes to him as
a character he's not as strong as you
would like himself to believe and so the
result here is that he's constantly
tormented Mephisto constantly constantly
plays and toys with the mind of doom
telling him that his soul is going to be
taken eventually that his mother's soul
was captured and that his soul will be
captured as well that he was doomed from
birth because his mother had been toying
around with you know mysticism because
she'd been messing with black magic she
had basically doomed her son to a fade
there would be the exact same as her own
and so what happens is that his doom is
making his way through this mountain
region he's eventually set upon by a
Yeti now this is kind of funny because
of normal comics these things do exist
yetis Bigfoot so on and so forth they do
exist you actually have when dingoes
which is that which is a literal being
and it's a it's basically kind of a like
a werewolf style plague that passes from
one person to the next
and it was a longtime enemy of Wolverine
for a time but the fact remains here
that doom is more or less on his own
there's no one here to come and rescue
him and facing off against a Yeti is a
very formidable threat somewhat because
of the fact that this yetis not wildly
intelligent but it is ferocious
and so doom uses what tools he has at
his disposal he does what he can against
this thing but in the end it really just
sort of resorts down to a bomb is
planted in the mouth of this Yeti that
allows it to explode now what Brubaker's
telling us here is that despite his lack
of magic Doom is not without his
resources he's an extremely resourceful
person and this really just builds into
his intelligence it builds into his
quick thinking it builds into his
aptitude for doing what it takes to get
out of a situation so long as he doesn't
allow himself to be overcome by that
situation but as he continues his
journey and makes his way he finally
finds this Tibetan temple on the side of
a mountain and when he enters all the
monks are absolutely stoked so to speak
you know to see him alive and well
and the reason why this matters is
because again tying in to the last video
Otto had stated that Doom was supposed
to be their leader doom was supposed to
be the guy who
come along and take the place of
leadership in this temple and so the
fact that doom survived is sort of
solidified this this belief system sort
of solidified this this legend that
these monks had that someone like doom
would come along and so what happens is
these monks have effectively blended
magic and Technology together but
they're two separate aspects to and so
doom basically learns how to manipulate
magic at the same time as learning how
to advance his own understanding of
Technology then this is what he does he
basically begins to meld the two
together at the behest of these of these
monks but he also begins to lay the
groundwork for becoming an effective
ruler and this is something that I
really hope you're noticing here because
with dr. doom he is cruel he is very
arrogant but he's also extremely
honorable when dr. doom makes a promise
he always keeps it regardless of the
circumstances it doesn't mean that he
agrees with it a lot of the time but it
does mean that he will keep it and so
because he's such an honorable person he
conveys this to his subjects he provides
them with the kind of things that they
need he allows them to view him
personally so that he's not considered
to be some sort of unnamed unseen leader
that they know nothing about and this
really stems from his experience with
the Baron because if you guys had
noticed in the earlier books we never
saw what the Baron looked like we never
knew who he was all we knew was that he
was just an unnamed guy now in the
original Stan Lee and Jack Kirby story
we did see that Baron but the goal that
Brubaker was going for here was to
basically show us some enigmatic being
out there who had tormented the very
life I guess all the lives of the Romani
villagers during dooms childhood and so
this would allow Brubaker to come back
now and to say instead of being some guy
out there that no one knows anything
about instead doom wants people to see
him they want them to know who he is now
again continuing his role as a leader
here he of course assembles various
forms of Technology different things
like that and starts monitoring all of
the the transmissions around the world
begins monitoring almost all these
things that are taking place at the same
time in order to understand exactly how
things have changed in the outside world
now again this is doom beginning to
become more of a Rekluse this is him
moving away from being so intertwined
with society and largely staying in and
of himself but what we also learned is
that wal Doom has been going on this
jerk
Reed Richards has been rising to
prominence now he has not yet become
Reed Richards mr. fantastic he is not
yet undergone you know the the
transformation and become part of the
Fantastic Four
instead he's simply just a guy who in a
lot of ways use the work of Victor Von
Doom to sort of bolster his own
reputation and this is really
interesting then this was actually
something that that hit been focused on
slightly but Hickman was really more
about the overarching disagreement zeal
rocking view of doom and Reacher and
Richards in terms of how they saw each
other as opposed to such small things
like this and this is why Brubaker so
good because he focuses on the little
bitty things it allows us to kind of
bolster into the entirety of Hickman's
run and understand why the feud between
Richards and dr. doom was so significant
but it also tells us that Reed is not
everything that we thought he's not
necessarily a guy that came up with all
his original ideas he's not a guy that
did all the work on his own instead he
used the work of Victor Von Doom in
order to you know increase his own his
own knowledge to increase his own
experience now Reed modified it you know
and Reed is an inherently good guy it's
simply just an example that not all that
glitters is gold and so what happens is
with this revelation with this
recognition that that his work is kind
of being thrown out there Doom has
somewhat of an existential crisis in the
sense that he starts to view you know
start to ask a question how does he
exist in relation to the rest of the
world and he starts having these
flashbacks and this is one of the most
important moments of the entire run of
the books of doom these flashbacks show
his relationship with valaria when they
were children it shows his experience
with his father when the two of them
raced off it showed the the presumed
death of his father and how doom almost
died as well but it shows basically
all the losses that he's experienced
over the course of his life and doom
comes to the realization that he is the
same as everybody else when it comes to
you know who people are on a fundamental
level that while he did see himself
above humanity as a whole the one thing
he's shared in common with them was
their fragility how easily he could be
killed and so what he decided to do was
basically create a form for himself that
would not be so easily destroyed create
a form for himself that would not only
inspire fear and those who saw him but
would give him and those who view him as
sense of his immortality that doomed
simply cannot be killed and so what
happens is he fashions his own armor
that we know now to be the Doctor Doom
armor now the reason why this is so
important is because this serves two
purposes again it's designed to inspire
fear you know for individuals who see
him but is also just as much for doom
himself the perception of being
indestructible the perception of being
unbeatable the perception of being
immortal is just as important is
actually being those things if you can
get people to believe something with
absolute truth they'll have no reason to
question it and that's dooms motivation
here if you can get people to believe
that he's immortal if you can get people
to believe that he's indestructible
because of how he looks then there is no
there's no way to work around that
there's no reason people to believe that
he is not immortal that he's not
indestructible and so again this is just
kind of a dual purpose here it really
just shows us that the the suit is not
just designed for arbitrary reasons this
suit actually has a purpose now if you
guys are interested I can actually do a
video on this suit of Doctor Doom kind
of running over it and talk about you
know what this suit is or what it's
capable of and all the things that it
can do but the fact remains as we bring
this video to an end basically this is
Doctor Doom going forward this is now
Victor Von Doom as we know him and so
what he does is he goes forward with the
intention of solidifying his legacy
which will ultimately lead him to
becoming the ruler of Latveria but
without being said let me know what you
guys think about this series again the
origin of Doctor Doom is incredible it's
one of the best stories that I think's
ever been released and yeah I will catch
you guys later peace
you
[Music]